You just created a histragram with bin size 20, but we can create a histagram
with any bin size, or also called the interval size. This is interactivate
histagram software, which I really like. You can just input the data here, and
then you can see how the shape of the histagram changes when you change the bin
size. So here, we're getting bigger and bigger bins. And you see that there are
more observations now within each interval. If we keep making the bin size
bigger and bigger, eventually it gets kind of hard to see the shape of the
histogram because the bin sizes are too big. So here, the bin size is about 23.
And if we keep going, of course, eventually, we get way too much data in each
bin, and the shape of the histogram isn't even recognizable. So, let's get a
smaller bin size. Here, you can kind of see better the shape of the histogram,
that it peaks at around age 20. And so, it's really up to you to decide what bin
size you want, and it all depends on what questions you want to answer. How much
detail you want. because at some point, the bin size is probably too small, but
at some point the bin size is probably too big. In this software, you can also
see that the sample size is 50. You can see the average. And we're going to get
to these statistics later. The link to this software is on the right, so you can
click on it and input the data. We shared this data with you in a Google
spreadsheet. And then, you can see for yourself how the shape of the histogram
changes when you change the bin size.